thank you for joining us America
cortney's with us in Battle Creek
Michigan hi Courtney how are you I'm
good how are you better than I deserve
what's up I have a question for you
about renting a car do you know a way
for me to rent a car without having a
credit card several levels several
companies will take debit cards
different ones have different policies
regarding the debit card are you renting
a car locally or are you getting off an
airplane with a return ticket off an
airplane if you're getting off an
airplane with a return ticket there's a
bunch of them that will okay I don't
have the list current in front of me but
just check with them Hertz is a problem
their problem children the last I heard
Avis was very good to work with on them
enterprises spotty
it depends enterprises and end up
they're independently operated and it
just depends on where you're getting off
the plane which city it is as to whether
enterprises have their heads stuck up
their butt or not but you could just
check with whoever you're talking to and
make sure sometimes they want something
else but usually if you have a returned
airline ticket and you're out of town
there's a whole bunch of them we'll do
it then but the ones to stay away from
will be Hertz be careful with enterprise
because it's spotty Avis I'm pretty sure
Avis just has a straight system we have
an account with Hertz
corporate accounts so I don't use a
debit card in that regard because I've
got a huge you know I've got out 600
people here in a bunch of his travels so
then that doesn't work so we don't use
that debit card in that way with them
but but my understanding is they just
don't take it or when they do they screw
around with you so I wouldn't use them
for it but you know one of these car
companies ought to actually get their
act together if they were smart and they
would get like me to tell everybody to
go use their debit card there because
they make it easy the one company that
makes it the easiest is and you know you
wouldn't even hardly have to pay me to
get me to do that if one of you would
just treat my listeners right but you
know these people these rent-a-car
places some of them are so corporate
there's such boobs
but if somebody if one if there's one
good company out there that we just go
we're going to treat debit card people
not like second-class citizens man I
would send you a bunch of business if
you did that so I can answer people like
Courtney all the time because this comes
up from time to time so but yeah Avis
I'm pretty sure is okay Courtney and
check Enterprise at your particular
locale and you can check Hertz you know
see what they're doing but I understand
their pain in the butt and gosh I think
Nationals does pretty good but just just
ask call a couple of them and ask I
would do I wouldn't book it online I
would talk to a human being you know and
try to find out you know exactly what
their policy is so you don't get into a
problem with it because some of them are
a problem but yeah you lots of people
rent cars with debit cards it's not that
unusual and a lot of our people do even
when they're not doing Hertz on one of
our contracts hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]